good afternoon everybody and
welcome today to today's event my name
is doug rogers i teach in the
anthropology department
and i'm the faculty director of the
program in russian east european and
eurasian studies
today is a special event not just
because of our guest who's one of the
most
well-known most distinguished and most
fascinating journalists and broadcasters
of the past 50 years
anywhere in the world but because in a
much
smaller and more modest way this is the
first time that the words program
in russian east european and eurasian
studies are being uttered in public
at yale applause is appropriate
um our program dates from uh july 1st
2018
um and we think that the interest that
we're hearing around campus and the
full auditoriums like today are good
evidence of expanding interest in uh
the study of um of this part of the
world
so thank you for coming look at our
website get on our newsletter we hope to
bring you many more
events like this i want to thank the
macmillan center
the council in european studies for
helping us with this event also and
especially the pointer fellowship in
journalism
and the office of public affairs and
communication eileen o'connor is
somewhere here
thank you very much for for your
partnership in this event and
many other events we've had in the past
and hope to have in the future
um the plan for today is that i will
turn things over to uh constantine
morovnik who i'm also very grateful to
for suggesting
uh this program and for doing a lot of
the work to make it happen
he'll introduce our guest uh who will
then speak for
a little while uh followed by a sort of
open
uh question and answer and discussion
period uh so without further ado
questions
uh it is my distinct honor to uh welcome
uh vladimir posner to yale uh mr posner
needs an introduction only from for
those who are
too young to remember the 80s and the
90s
in this country when he regularly
appeared on ted
uh couples nightline and the phil
donahue show
and then co-hosted the posner donahue
show on cnbc
at that time he once visited yale so
it's not
a welcome but a welcome back mr posner
may also need an introduction to those
who are detached from contemporary
russia
where he is omnipresent in the media for
the past 10 years he has hosted a weekly
show
posner where he interviews various
national
and world leaders from all walks of life
gorbachev sakura gaidar
shoigu ted turner and vexelberg hillary
clinton and sting
michael mcfaul and xenia among many
others
had a chance to face mr posner's
thoughtful scrutiny
and be judged by millions of russian
viewers
mr posner's opinions on a wide range of
questions from politics to soccer
from history to gastronomy and arts
quickly go
viral they have become a fact of
russian life to such an extent that he
has been termed
half seriously half and just the
spiritual leader of the nation
and its moral compass this is despite
the fact that mr posner is russian just
as much
as he is an american or french he was
born in france
and christened in notre dame grew up in
the u.s
and came to russia only at the age of
19.
perhaps this cosmopolitan aspect of his
biography
is what endears him to russian public
tired like any other public
of ideological agendas perhaps this
ability
to be simultaneously russian and
american and european
attunes mr posner to the subtleties of
different perspectives
and brings him one step closer to the
much desired
and less and and no less appreciated
objectivity
and truth especially now when the gaps
separating governments and nations
are only widening and one side
increasingly refuses to consider
the views of the other in his more than
five
decades in the field of journalism mr
posner has done his share
of partisanship and propaganda however
this changed in the 80s when he
pioneered a project of so-called space
bridges
or tele-bridges that connected russian
and american audiences
moscow viewers named him tv journalist
number one
in 1989 and this high mark of
recognition
has never decreased ever since in 1989
and in uh from 1994 to 2008 mr posner
headed the russian television academy
in 1997 he founded the school for
television excellence
a plot a platform for an education and
promotion of young journalists
he's written several books and made a
number of documentary mini series
about different countries their cultures
and people
these films brought the us france italy
germany
england israel and spain closer to
millions of russian people
it is my hope that this conversation
with mr posner at yale
will also achieve what he has been so
good at
that it will bring russian views and
opinions a little closer to our students
and colleagues
and will maintain what we all need now
the most
a dialogue based on mutual understanding
and respect
so please join me in welcoming vladimir
[Applause]
posner
quite an introduction um
i'd like to say a couple of words about
who i am and what i am notwithstanding
what we just heard um it's important
that you understand that i don't
represent anybody
um or anything
any organization political social
whatever i represent myself
i am an independent journalist
and that's an animal that is
disappearing
in russia and not only in russia
um i think uh for me it's important that
i say that and i hope
i'm going i'm not going to speak long
because i was told that we would have a
conversation afterwards
and i think that might be the most
interesting part of it because
you have questions or views that you
might want to share with me
and i can't guess them in advance but
there are certain things i'd like to say
before we have that conversation i'd
like to
say first of all that we are at an
extremely
dangerous moment today
never have the relations between russia
and the united states or the soviet
union that's what it was before
been at this level during the worst
times of the cold war
when i was living in the soviet union
and i remember all that
very very well russians were
anti-white house
anti-wall street but not anti-american
in their vast majority in fact
there was a kind of a warm feeling visit
the americans
today that's different today it's
anti-american
at the grassroots level
and there's a reason for it
another thing that is to me scary
is that neither side seems to be afraid
of nuclear weapons 30 years ago
those of you who are of my age certainly
remember an american
movie called the day after which is
about what happens to you into your
country
after a nuclear strike there was
fear of these weapons as there was in
the soviet union there was a realization
that these weapons can and if used will
destroy our country today there's a
feeling
when you talk to people it's as if there
are no nuclear weapons
it really doesn't seem to play a role
in how we act and the danger of a
not a deliberate nuclear exchange
but an accidental one has grown
because the level of mistrust between
the two countries has grown as well
there have been several times in the
past when computers
warned of a nuclear attack
but it never got to the real thing
because people took the time to really
check it out
now they didn't have a long time if a
nice icbm is launched from russia
it will take about 10 minutes for it to
hit the us
so you never and vice versa obviously
um so you don't have a long time but you
do have some
but my feeling is that if today those
same computers malfunctioned
and said on either side that
an attack has been launched the response
would be immediate
because the feeling is that this is
what's going to happen
not that long ago we were all very
optimistic weren't we
gorbachev gorby gourmet russians were
going to be friends we're going to be
and in such a really short period of
time what
how did this happen why are we at the
point
that we are today and i'm not saying
who's to blame
because that's not a productive way of
looking at things
but we should try to understand exactly
what did happen
the soviet union once gorbachev
took over didn't really last very long
he came to power in march of 1985
and by december 1991 there was no more
soviet union
it some people say it collapsed
didn't collapse in a place called the
belarus which is a kind of a forest
three presidents the president of
ukraine the president of belarus
and the president of russia proper mr
yeltsin
decided to part company
decided to disband the soviet union
now each had his own reasons definitely
but if we look at mr yeltsin his reason
was very clear
he was the president of russia so he was
number
two to gorbachev because gorbachev was
president of
the soviet union of which russia was
part
the largest part but only part get rid
of the soviet union
and there's no president and you get rid
of
gorbachev and that's precisely what he
did
so no more soviet union quickly no more
warsaw pact of course
that is to say countries that were
usually called soviet satellites
and part of a military alliance with the
soviet union that alliance disappeared
and so the united states had to figure
out
how do we deal with this new entity
called russia
how do we deal with it there's no more
soviet union
what is going to be u.s policy
thee this country and of course
yeltsin also had to think about what is
going to be
russia's attitude
towards the united states
um you may remember that uh
soon after the soviet union ceased to
exist
and i think it was february of 1992
um yeltsin came to the united states
and he addressed a joint session of
congress
and he said the people of russia are
offering their hand
to the people of the united states in
friendship
to build a better world a world without
war
a world without peace and this was
exactly what the vast majority of
russians
wanted and i would even say that today
the vast majority of russians would like
to have if not a friendship
with the united states at least a
partnership
there's no doubt to my mind that that's
the case
so that was what yeltsin wanted and what
kind of response
did he get what kind of response
did russia get well
the united states could have picked two
ways of
treating russia one was to say let's
treat
russia like we did our enemies after
world war ii
germany italy and as some of the
countries that were occupied
such as france or were not occupied such
as uk but were really
badly hurt let's find a way to see
to it that in those countries nazis
fascists do not come back
and communists do not come to power and
may remind you that in those days
the communist party of france and the
communist party of italy were very very
powerful and that plan turned out
was called later the marshall plan
which was basically a financial
idea to spend a lot of money
but in a very precise way to develop
certain things
and not to allow others to develop
now that could be the policy
to adopt visiting russia see to it that
democracy begins to develop in that
country
and let me say just for the record
russia
never in its entire thousand years
never had democracy completely
absent so it wasn't like something that
once upon a time
russians had and then they lost but they
knew what it was
they didn't know what it was
so let's spend money on
getting democracy moving in russia and
seeing to it
that the communists do not get back
and that could have been one approach
the other approach was to say
for 40 years you held
a nuclear bomb over our heads
you lost the cold war and you're going
to pay for it
you're going to be punished for what you
did
and there were people who supported one
view and people who supported the other
in this country
early in 1992
a document was produced in the united
states by a gentleman called
paul wolfowitz you may know who he was
he was under secretary of defense of the
united states
responsible for policy the document he
produced came to be called
the wealth of its doctrine not
officially but that's the way it was
addressed
it later was incorporated in something
that has officially called the bush
doctrine
that document was leaked to the new york
times
and so it became public and what it
basically said
and you can look it up it's available
you know just go to off of its uh
doctrine and you'll find it what it
basically said was this
the united states should never again
allow
any other country to challenge it
the united states must remain the
superior country and we should tell our
allies not to worry about developing
their own weapons because we will do
that for them
and we must watch out for russia
because we can we don't know which way
it's going to go the bear
might get up on his hind legs again and
growl
when that document was leaked to the new
york times there was an outcry
by the more liberal if you will
in america now the word liberal and
conservative
has lost the meaning that once upon a
time had
so when i say libra i'm not sure that
i'm saying the right word but at least
many people were upset by this document
edward kennedy said that it was an
imperialist document
that no country could or should accept
it was quickly as it were removed
and rewritten by um
mr cheney not a very liberal man in any
sense as far as i can remember
and um um
the secretary of defense in those days
mr powell
but basically it retained that view
russia and america must remain must be
the only
superpower
and basically that view was the one that
was accepted
it was the one that would accept it and
the attitude towards russia was pretty
much
you're no longer a superpower
you are a second-rate country
just just keep quiet please
uh this became evident
and would be evident to you if you
follow the policy
of the united states now let's begin
with
going back to gorbachev and his meetings
when he was asked by
several people all of them quite
important to
allow germany to reunite and take down
the berlin wall
and he was told by james baker and now
this is
not many people i mean when i would say
this many people say it's not true it's
not true
he was told by james baker if this
happens
nato will not move one inch eastward
well not long ago on december 12
2017 the national defense archives
of george washington university
declassified the minutes
of the baker gorbachev discussion and
it's there
but it's not only baker who said that to
him there were several people did
the german leadership did west driven at
those days and so on
and finally i'm not saying i don't know
whether
whether gorbachev could have stopped
germany from reuniting but the fact of
the matter is
that they said yes and took down the
berlin wall
and nato stayed put it stayed put
in those days it stayed put under bush
senior
it stayed put during the first four
years
of clinton but in the next four years
in 1996 approximately a decision was
taken
to enlarge
nato three countries poland
the czech republic and hungary
now i'm going to read something to you
uh you know who thomas friedman is new
york times
old hand uh columnist
he uh when this happened this is already
19 this is um
1998. he called up george kennan
i don't know if you're all aware who
george cannon was but he was one
in my opinion perhaps one of the most
brilliant minds political minds
of the united states the second half of
the 20th century
the man who devised the idea of
containment
of the soviet union rather than war
against the soviet
union successfully did this so
you know a brilliant man who uh
who established the the very foundation
of u.s policy
visiting the soviet union so thomas
friedman called him up the article he
published
in the new york times is called foreign
affairs now
a word from x why x because in 1947
in the magazine foreign affairs
mr cannon had published this article
about containment
and he signed it x so he called him up
and he asked him what did he think about
this decision
to enlarge nato let me quote
i think this is may 2 1998.
i think it is the beginning of a new
cold war
said mr cannon from his princeton home
i think the russians will gradually
react quite adversely
and it will affect their policies i
think
it is a tragic mistake there was no
reason for this
whatsoever
that decision and now i'm giving you my
opinion
is what really started this this
relation with turning it south as you
might say
that's where it all began because the
russian reaction
and specifically this is 1998 so
this is yeltsin late yeltsin
was you promised
not to do this so
how do we trust you if you make a
promise
i would also like you to perhaps try to
um solve a little problem it's a kind of
a
not mathematical take the time
from when gorbachev came to power march
1985 to 2007
when putin has been in power for seven
years that's 22 years
i ask you to find a single thing
in foreign or domestic policies
done by the soviet union wealth that
existed
and then russia proper that might in any
way
anger irk disappoint
the united states
let me answer that for you nothing
not one thing during that period
now what did russia get as a result of
that
first the enlargement of nato
so that was number one then the bombing
of yugoslavia
that was done by nato and nato is after
all
dependent mostly on the united states
let's face it right
uh the u.n did not condone this so the
bombing of yugoslavia
that's uh from march 24th 99 to june
10th
99. then uh
kosova and recognition of kosovo though
it had been part of serbia for centuries
and there were people in russia who said
you're letting
the jinn out of the bottle because if
you do this then there are other
countries that will do the same
and russia did the same there's a
diaphragm
to begin with okay
yeltsin was very angry he made a speech
he said
and of course this is very yeltsin-like
he said we're not
haiti you can't treat us like haiti
we're a great country we have
a great past and russia will come back
russia will come back he was really
really
angered didn't say the politically
correct thing
but he spoke his mind
uh then finally
2000 the year 2000 mr putin
is not elected although elected
um to the presidency and one of the
first things he does
is to ask for russia
to become a member of nato
why not be a member of nato nato was
created
to defend europe and perhaps not only
europe
from soviet aggression
from a country that you couldn't predict
there is no more soviet union
and there is no more warsaw pact why
can't we
create an organization where we're part
of it said mr putin
and act together to protect from
some kind of aggression he was told
go take a walk basically
what about some kind of partnership or
becoming part of the european union
again and this is all documented
everything i say
except when i say my opinion is
documented you can look it up
and he said they were no you know you're
too big
your country country's too big you can't
uh and all the while
russia was being reminded that
it's no longer really that important the
country
now one of the things you must keep in
mind
is that much like the americans the
russians believe
that they have a mission that their
country was selected by destiny
now you know my being french i laugh at
that i laugh both at you and at them
because we french know that we're the
best and we have no no
no we have no mission you know that's it
but seriously speaking and that's a fact
and so the sense of losing this
this this aura of greatness
of being told we don't care about you
the uh the reaction of the average
russian to that was one of
you're you're insulting me you're not
you don't respect me
and so the anger gradually
and the anger focused on gorbachev
many many russians figured you sold the
country
you don't stand up to these men to these
to the united states
and then the same thing for yeltsin
you'd be surprised
how unpopular gorbachev and yeltsin are
today in russia
maybe five percent support them
precisely for that reason well there are
some others as well that have to do with
economic things but nonetheless so now
here we have putin
who as you know as soon as 9 11 happens
calls up bush jr
w and offers his help
and yes and does help in afghanistan
and if you want to have your soldiers
your military people
in in central asia right on our borders
be my guest and in georgia absolutely
so it's not just words you know we we
want to fight
terrorism together
and uh gets nothing in in
in exchange so finally
in 2007 in munich
um speaking to the 20 the group of 20
in munich putin says this
this is february 10th i think it is
obvious that nato expansion does not
have
any relation with the modernization of
the alliance itself
with ensuring security in europe
on the contrary it represents a serious
provocation
that reduces the level of mutual trust
and we have the right to ask against
whom
is this expansion intended
and what happened to the assurance of
our western partners
made after the dissolution of the warsaw
pact
where are those declarations today
no one even remembers them
but i will allow myself to remind this
audience what was said
i would like to quote the speech of
general secretary mr
werner of brussels on may 17
1990 he said at the time
quote the fact that we are not
ready to place a nato army outside
of german territory gives the soviet
union
a firm security guarantee
where are these guarantees and do you
know what the answer was
the answer was yes but that was
guarantees given to the soviet union
and you're russia
well what kind of a reaction would you
expect
um last year i think it was
making a foreign policy speech putin
said
our mistake was that we trusted you too
much
and your mistake was that you tried to
take advantage of that
that is the situation today now it may
seem to you that i'm
blaming the united states i don't want
the word blame used
it was a mistaken political decision
it was not the russians it was this
decision
that finally led to this change
in putin's attitude towards the west and
in particular
towards the united states which is why i
say how u.s policy created
putin the way he is today
and the really if you will um
um dangerous thing
is that russian leadership i should be
more precise and say
vladimir putin does not trust
the west does not trust the united
states
which makes it very difficult to move
away
from where we are today so that
something i want to underline so we are
in now in a new arms race
which is terrible we are in a new cold
war
which threatens all of us
the danger of an accidental nuclear
exchange
has grown we no longer seem to fear that
there used to be demonstrations you know
get rid of nuclear weapons
that's not happening anymore
the possibility of a terrorist
organization
somehow getting a nuclear weapon
has grown and to make it look like
someone used it on each side not the
terrorists
so that i believe is something we should
all
understand and finally
as someone who works in media i would
like to say that
russian media a mainstream i'm
i mean mainstream media paints
america black russian media
mainstream media controlled directly or
indirectly by the government
shows a an extremely negative picture
of the united states u.s policy and so
on
and much to my surprise mainstream
american media does exactly the same
thing
vis-a-vis russia which to me
is amazing because this is supposed to
be a free media
that's differing from the russian one as
someone who works in russian media i can
say
it's hard to call it a free media
there are some opposition newspapers and
radio but that's not mainstream
they address a very small number of
people
so there we are i think i think people
who call themselves journalists in my
book they're they're not journalists but
those people have played
and are playing a destructive role
in creating the fear the dislike
the distrust that the people in both
countries have
visiting each other and the fact that
we don't seem to question our media
is really quite interesting
but there it is nonetheless we just take
it
so i'd like to wind up
with a quote from a gentleman no i
hesitate to use the word gentleman
from a man whose name was herman goering
you all know who he was there may be
some people who are too young to know
well he was hitler's
right-hand man and he commanded the
luftwaffe
the german air force
and he was of course at nuremberg he was
judged getting sentenced to death to
hang
but he managed to get some poison
probably from the soviets of course
since they poisoned people as we know
so and so is not to be hanged
but he was um interviewed by an american
journalist shortly before he
committed suicide and
here's what he said and i think this is
something that we should all remember
naturally the common people don't want
war
neither in russia nor in england nor for
that matter in germany
that is understood but after all
it is the leaders of the country who
determine the policy
and it is always a simple matter to drag
the people along
whether it is a democracy
or a fascist dictatorship or a
parliament
or a communist dictatorship
voice or no voice the people can always
be brought
to the bidding of the leaders
that is easy all you have to do
is tell them they are being attacked
and denounce the peacemakers for a lack
of patriotism
and exposing the country to danger
it works the same in any country
said mr goering and i think he was
absolutely right
and we are being led by our media
by our politicians in that direction
in both countries i remember an
ad that i saw a famous american actor
whose name i who he starred in um oh
gosh so many movies
um an afro an african-american um
um not a young not not a yeah
freeman yes yes and he says
we are at war and he does it very well
he's a wonderful actor
but he you know he tells you
we are at war and we must
and of course it's very scary
i you know i there's nothing i can do
about that
except speak and i speak
i'm happy to speak here today i do this
in russia
and i'll keep doing it as long as i
possibly can
because there has to be some voice
raised against what's happening
we're being manipulated you know the way
putin is portrayed well he's worse than
hitler
and even even hillary clinton compared
him to hitler i mean
this is i'm not a putin fan believe me
but you know what's what's going on here
and of course
president trump well even your own
press is not too uh not too positive
about him but
anyway so basically that's what i wanted
to share with you and see i've only
spoken for 45 minutes
and uh and i would very much like to
discuss
uh if you i hope you have problems and
uh problems
quentin uh uh that was a freudian slip
wasn't it
uh i hope uh you have questions
i'm sure that you know what i've just
said
in the sense of what's happened it can't
be argued about i mean this is these are
facts
but how you interpret them that's a
whole different issue
so thank you again for
for listening and let's let's talk
so i am uh acutely aware of which one of
us has more experience
in this kind of a forum so i i think i
will skip
uh the part where i ask the first
question and open it up for questions
and
and uh and comments with the following
uh suggestions and guidelines um
we have two microphones uh please wait
for a microphone you may think that you
have a loud voice but the people behind
you will not agree so please wait
um for the microphone please uh be aware
of the fact that we have
uh some limited time for a conversation
and a lot of us so please keep your
questions
uh reasonably brief and we'll and we'll
try to keep things moving and we'll move
back and forth
from side to side so
i'm going to start on this side
go ahead sir i'm very interested
in your take on
russian interference
the u.s intelligence overwhelmingly
concluded that russia
is involved in u.s elections and i don't
think i'm over i'm over assuming in
saying that
the russians are in favor of the
republicans
so i'm very interested in your take on
that well i think that's a you know a
question a lot of people have
i'm happy to answer it as well as i can
i wouldn't say that the russians
support the republicans i mean the
russians don't really know who the
republicans are
it's not part of their daily interest or
the democrats for that
matter but is this microphone working
yeah okay but it is a fact that
republican presidents over the years
have been the ones that have achieved
breakthroughs with the soviet union
nixon did when jews were allowed to
emigrate this was 1972.
um bush did reagan did
while the democratic ones such as carter
and
uh and uh clinton um have not been so
successful but that's
russians did support including the
russian leadership uncertain
did support trump now look they had a
choice
hillary clinton uh hillary clinton or
donald trump
hillary clinton said that that uh
putin was a former kgb agent
and had no soul
and compared him to hitler
trump said i think i can work with this
man
i think we can do this now
yes the russians wanted him to win
and i think that's normal
did the russians interfere
officially putin denies it
the russians officially deny it
u.s intelligence different intelligence
says it can't furnish the exact proof
but it is certain that they did
i've been reading just recently you know
there was this
huge um i don't know how many pages
a special issue in new york times
about the you know pages and pages with
with
wonderful um wonderful illustrations
that are supposed to really prove you
know like
like this you know this kind of thing
this is journalism interesting isn't it
um and when you read the article very
carefully
and you ask yourself it's not an article
it's one two
three four with graphics
five six
six pages of the new york times
and when you read it carefully you ask
yourself
why was it published now
there's got to be a reason for this
right i mean this happened a while ago
what is the idea and what you find
at the very tail end
is that over the past
few years in this country
the popularity of mr putin has increased
by 11 percent
and the number of people who believe
that the russians interfered has gone
down by five
that's a good reason to publish
something like this
and this is a very detailed interesting
um story that doesn't furnish any proof
but it's very well done is the new york
times gnosis
this is just one so i said this came out
september 20th
the next one comes out in time magazine
which is october 1st not yet their big
story
on the same thing but this is again the
interference of the russians
and then we have another story in the
new york times
september 26th so i'm saying to myself
wow this is like a kind of a salvo
cannons are going and i have to ask
myself is there a reason for this
and i would ask you you know why now
does this have to do with the midterm
elections
i think it probably does now
did the russians interfere i think they
probably did
i think they probably did um
[Music]
was that effective i doubt it
i very much doubt it they didn't
spend a whole lot of money about a
hundred thousand dollars
which is really nothing when you talk
about the elections
but they did you know some interesting
stuff if you will
i i believe that to actually think that
trump
won the election because of russian
interference
you have to be very naive for that i
mean a farmer in idaho
was influenced by russian propaganda
i mean i worked in russian soviet
propaganda for many years
and i'm not of the highest how should i
say this
i mean it's not that great that
propaganda you know
it's not something i'm proud of what i
did i mean perhaps
what i do today is because of what i did
back then you know john maya culpa
but um really
was putin the man who said let's do this
i don't know i can't say yes or no to
that
i'm a journalist give me proof give me
proof
and i'll say yes or no depending on that
but i think yeah there was probably an
attempt
to do it and so what
does america ever interfere in elections
anywhere
never you know why is it why is it okay
for you and not okay for them
you know that that's a question well i
got an answer to that from one
former cia
high-ranking gentleman he said well you
see yes we do interfere
but we interfere for good and you went
to care for that
so i thought well that's it that's you
know so that's how it answers your
question
i would say yes i would not exaggerate
the the result of that the impact of it
and i would say that it's being used as
a political toy
ploy in this country now for a variety
of reasons
and it only really surfaced after
hillary lost
before that it wasn't there but you had
to find a reason
why she lost and of course it was the
big bad russian bear
and that's par for the course isn't it
let's have the next question what is
your opinion of the past
trump uh putin meeting and you think it
was for show
or do you think it's actually a reason
trying to
better their relations even if it was
for show it was good it was good for
how should i put this for public feeling
at last these two men
one of whom is the president of the most
powerful country in the world
and the other is the president of a
country that has 10 000 nuclear warheads
and may not be that powerful but is very
dangerous these two men
have gotten together and that in itself
is positive
um nothing was really achieved
but i would say that one of the
important thing is it seems to me
that the two men kind of like each other
and that's very important you know
gorbachev and reagan
were completely different human beings i
mean completely
but they like each other
and they achieved some really incredible
breakthroughs when you think about
so i think it was a good thing i think
it was a first step
of course here the reaction to it was
very negative because supposedly well
you know what uh
what trump said that he trusted
putin and that he trusted his
intelligence
so it was kind how can you trust both
they're saying
opposite things
and um there was a lot of talk about the
fact that he lost to putin what did he
lose
he gave putin the opportunity to be on
the same stage with him
that's true that's true did that
increase
putin's stature i don't think so i don't
think so at all
and i hope that there's a next meeting i
hope there is
i hope that somehow that there will be
an attempt to uh
to break out of the situation that we're
in now i mean
i'm not again i'm not a big fan of mr
trump's
but even if he tries to do something the
congress
the u.s congress seems hell-bent on not
allowing that
and i don't know why now if
if the american establishment
wants regime change in russia
wants putin out and someone different
in if that is the aim
of the people who are
who run this country let's put it that
way
that is uh extremely dangerous
it's not going to happen it's not going
to happen
russians are living worse today than
they did five years ago
the sanctions are hurting but the
average russian is saying
we're being punished for things we never
did
this is not fair this is
the american bully throwing his weight
around
and we'll take it we can take it
and i think that's true the russians the
tougher it is
the more tough they become they're
pretty weak when things are good
no it's true but when things are tough
that's when they're really you know
and i was reading this
book by arthur schlesinger
jr it's called the cycles of american
history
and he dwells on 1850
when you know there were revolutions in
europe in 1848
and there was a hungarian revolution and
the leader of that revolution was a man
called kofut
and finally that revolution was and he
i was destroyed by the austrians and the
russians
and so speaking in congress
an american senator
said that the united states
should interfere this is 1850
and um senator hale
and there's this quote he said
the future historian might start off his
chapter about the year 1850 in the
following manner
at the commencements of this year the
american senate
the highest legislative body of the
world
the wisest greatest and most
magnaminous people that ever lived or
ever will live
forgetting and neglecting the trifling
local affairs which concerned their own
limits
constituted themselves into a high court
and proceeded to try the nations of the
earth
for atrocious acts of despotism wow
1850 the idea that the united states has
the right
to interfere in other countries because
they behave badly
from the u.s or other point of view that
was from a u.s point of view
1850 well then you begin to understand a
lot of other things
because that's what the united states
has done time and time again
but when another country does that
that's not permissible
so in syria if the us goes in
to protect the so-called and support the
so-called
so-called moderate opposition
and the russians go in to support
saddam not savannah
as i said the americans can do it that's
okay
the russians can't you know where's your
logic here
it's a tit-for-tat thing isn't it so
you know that's that's pretty much in in
my view the uh
the answer here that's how i look at
this issue
is there someone over on this side are
we done no no keep going there's
a question right over here
be helpful if you would also identify
yourselves before you asked your
question
my name is rob forman i work for the
medical school here
i used to listen to you on radio moscow
so that was a long time ago
see the gray hairs yeah well
but i'd like to frame it a little
differently
that i'm not so sure i perceive
americans to be
hating what russia did in interfering
although america has some of that
attitude that you described
but disliking
the fact that someone who is largely
considered to be an
incompetent president who does not have
the interest of this country
at heart is
beholden to the russians even if the
russians
what they did was comparable to what the
americans have done in
central america and who knows where else
and on that basis
uh i guess my question is a do you think
that analysis
is accurate and b why not if if not
because i don't know that it is so much
an attack on
what the russians did in 2016
as on the person who seems to be
in the pocket of those who did it
well i would say this that
was kennedy used to say i'll say this to
that right
um i will say this
the uh
what i said initially when i compared
what trump was saying during the
presidential campaign and what
hillary was saying it's obvious to
anyone
that the russians would support trump
it's obvious and americans should
understand that
not because of what trump stands for not
because he's a
uh whatever he is not because he wants
uh the supreme court to be more
conservative
russians don't care about that they
don't even it's not part of what they
think
but they think about the relationship
between russia and the united states
and judging from what he said back then
the relationship could improve
and that's basically it on the one hand
on the other hand
you recall as well as i do how many um
american senators i mean senators how
many
political figures said that the russians
were trying to destroy american
democracy what does that mean
how so that the aim of the russians
was to somehow destroy american
democracy
there's none of that so i can understand
what you're saying
but it really is not at all it doesn't
correspond
to what mr putin or the majority of
people in russia really
cared about or care about today today
there's much less support
for donald trump in russia than there
was people are asking themselves who the
hell is this man
he comes here and he says one thing and
he goes away and says something
completely different
you know today he says yes tomorrow he
says no to the same thing
so there are lots of questions and
there's kind of a
should i put this they don't take him
too seriously anymore
except it he has enormous power
my name's alexander i'm an undergraduate
you touched on in the beginning of your
talk about how there's intense
american hatred in russia and just now
you say that
you know most russians would want to
improve relations why do you think
how does that help putin to have like a
very bad relations
with america or like a bad image of
americans and russian minds
and also do you think that this hatred
is reciprocal like
is there a distrust of or dislike of
russians in america
i think the word hatred is a bit strong
and i didn't use it i said that the the
relation the the attitude of russians
today towards american
is more negative than it was back during
the cold war the worst times and i think
it's
it's mutual and i think that that's
the result of
uh what the politicians have said what
they've done
and what the media is doing in both
countries
and i think it's an issue of political
will
because before gorbachev came to power
in russia in the soviet union excuse me
um the attitude was negative in this
country very negative towards
the soviet union and the russians you
know the russians are the russians are
coming
i know just that but as soon as
gorbachev started changing things
uh glossness perestroika
suddenly he became gorby he became
you know america's favorite guy
so i think that if there is a a
desire on both sides
to change that attitude it can be done
very quickly
and that's why i say that we're
manipulated we are manipulated
and we all say oh i'm totally
independent
it's not true we get our we
we make our um decisions and we
we come to certain conclusions because
of what we read
because of what we see and because of
what we hear
so basically that's it
i would i would say that certainly the
internet allows us to get a much
broader picture in fact we could
communicate
with the other side via the internet
it's not happening very much but it is a
little bit
so that the the uh how should i put this
the ordinary citizen
could do a lot to change what's
happening
in both countries and it's a two-way
street
and i think it's people like you that is
to say of your age
they're the ones who for me are the
reason for optimism
because you can do this whereas people
of my age
and slightly younger
can do far less so i would hope that
you know what i've said today
might lead you to look into this and i
don't say to anyone believe me
trust me heaven forbid look into it
that's all i would say so i was struck
in in both your talk and and now
your um sort of mutual indictment of the
media on both sides and i was
i've been curious for a while about
how this may or may not be different to
what
this picture looked like say in the late
in the in the mid 1980s
i wonder if you could recall so so just
take the new york times i mean i wonder
if you could recall with
you know what new york times reporting
about russia about the soviet union was
like
in the 80s yeah and whether you see a
significant difference let me give you
an example
back in the 1970s 1980s
all of the major television networks
which are the most powerful
in the sense of affecting back then
especially
affecting people's views all three of
the major networks abc
cbs and nbc had bureaus
in moscow
the head of the abc bureau was a woman
by the name of ann garros
well that was a rare thing in those
years for a bureau to have a woman as a
chief
not only that but she spoke russian and
i'd like to tell you that
the vast majority of american
journalists did not speak russian
they had interpreters she did
and one day when and i met her at some
reception
and i was doing the show that you know i
did for moscow radio
um and we talked and she said you should
be on
u.s television i said well
you know how does that happen she called
up ted koppel you remember who
he was right nightline
i hope she's not forgotten and she said
you know ted instead of having
dissidents on all the time who represent
0.0 point something of
the country of the soviet union should
put on someone who can
can express the soviet viewpoint and who
can do it in english
so i got on nightline
and since i was not your typical russian
as far as
the american audience was concerned who
is this
uh i had great ratings and so i was on
again
and again and again and then on nbc and
cbs and here and there
today that wouldn't happen
i was allowed to argue
the soviet dew point on american
television
i was allowed to do that ted would
invite someone from the state department
to rebut me and very often the state
department would say
we're not going to do this because
posner's a pain in in the whatsapp
and we don't want to talk to him that's
fine
today i would not get that possibility
to be on
a major network regularly
and that's what's changed that's what's
really changed
and i've come to think
that government censorship official or
not official when the soviet union was
official
there was an official sensor you had to
go with your beast and the center would
read it
stamp it censorship today that doesn't
exist in russia
but of course there's censorship when
you know that the boss says no you can't
say that
or you can't print that so
and i'm talking now about mainstream
media right so
i call that government censorship but
there's something that i call
um uh
company censorship
and it's just as effective and what's
happened with american media much to my
regret
is that what used to be independent you
know
cnn belonged to ted turner
and he ran it cbs was
created by william paley and he ran it
but gradually many of these
very important sources were bought
by larger companies cnn
he sold it to nbc nbc was bought by aol
abc by disney and so
these very important media uh
whatever organizations became part
of huge conglomerates and information
was then very made very different
the attitude towards what media is
supposed to do
changed dramatically i asked
a group of people i paid for it actually
to try to find in the new york times
over the past three years 19
2015 1617 any positive article
about russia one
positive article didn't find any
not one now i say to myself if that
isn't censorship
then what is it i mean there have to be
people
who come to russia and say gee
they have good ice cream you know
or they have great theater and they do
and people are in standing in line for
theater tickets
and that's that's a nice thing right
give a a more or less accurate
no it's all negative
and that's the new york times
let alone everything else
that and it it's to me it's terribly
disappointing
because i was you know i worked here for
many
cnbc for quite a few years until a man
by the name of roger ailes
i don't know if you recall who that was
he killed our program
because he we were too liberal
just didn't resume the contract and that
was that
so i know what freedom of the press is
on both sides of the fence as it were
that's a different issue so that's what
i'm saying that we
in a strange way corporate censorship
is just as effective and sometimes far
more sophisticated
than government censorship i think we're
over on this side of the room and people
in the middle are
also welcome to ask questions somewhere
where i see a headway in the back well
actually you could lob the microphone
so um my name is rick schneider i work
with rivendell institute at yale
where are you right here oh okay thank
you uh i'm also a visiting professor
have been at gimo and currently at
vuichka
yes so um my question is from your
discussions experience with leaders
in russia do you sense any room for
compromise on ukraine i mean after all
the
the maybe the big sticking point right
now in our relations is
all of those sanctions most of the
sanctions other than magnitsky of course
but the
most the sanctions are about ukraine and
donbass is a big problem so
is there room for compromise to fix that
i think first of all i applaud the
question
because the key word is compromise the
key word is compromise
um i had asked for
the possibility to show a map
is that still possible or is that not
possible anymore
i i want to answer your question
because i want to show something that i
think is important i asked
oh my
i
i asked that a map of
russia with ukraine
uh be put up on the screen and hopefully
it will take to take a couple of seconds
okay i'm in no hurry and
a map of the united states and mexico
be put up on the screen
now
um let me go back to
the cuban missile crisis
1962. two totally
independent leaders
nikita khrushchev and fidel castro
decide that it would be a good idea
for russia to deploy missiles on cuban
soil
did they have the right to make that
decision absolutely
two independent countries and fidel
castro
was not a satellite that for sure
so is that oh okay
so they make that agreement and the
soviets begin
bringing in the missile well the parts
to assemble
and the united states discovers this
that's not that's
kennedy says to the russians
turn your ships around or we will sink
them
and if that leads to world war iii so be
it
and the russians turn their ships around
but there was a compromise
not made public in this country at that
time
kennedy agreed to pull out
american missiles that were deployed in
turkey
in exchange because the russians said
look
you have missiles in turkey right on our
border almost
you say our missiles are an existential
threat well so are yours
take them out and we will not deploy
ours
that was a compromise now kennedy asked
that this not be made public because it
would kind of be
seen as a loss of face and blah blah
blah and it wasn't made public and then
it would
so that was a compromise
and it it helped avoid world war three
well this is not yet happening we may
you may have to sort of ask
folks to conjure in their minds aye all
right um
i will do that yes i think you can get
if you want to do so now
um the russian leadership
sees nato as an existential threat
rightly or wrongly that's not the point
the point is that that's the way it
seems
and this is not politics you know why
would you
bring nato closer and closer to our
borders they say
in latvia it's on the border in estonia
it's on the border now
ukraine
is being is moving westward
it's a complicated issue the united
states has played a certain role in this
that's not the point it's moving
westward if
it ultimately
goes into the western fold or whatever
you want to call it
then it's logical to surmise that
ukraine will join the european union
and will become a nato member
now ukraine has a border
with russia not only that
but crimea which was traditionally
russian but i'm not
we can go into the the complicated
thing about how how ukraine was russia
that was not a russian uh
but not the point but sevastopol
was always the base of the navy the
russian navy
naval fleet of the black sea so
if crimea remains
ukrainian and if ukraine becomes part of
nato
the russian fleet won't be sevastopol
but the american 60
might very well be there and nato will
be on
russia's southwest border and the
russians
see this as an existential danger
and they say we will not permit it
now does that correspond to
international law
no it doesn't when you talk about
existential threat you say i don't care
about international law
as in the cuban missile crisis you say
no we don't give a damn how you feel
we're not going to allow this
it is my opinion that had from the very
outset
um been some kind of internationally um
negotiated
agreement that ukraine would not become
a member of nato for at least the next
50 years
there would be no ukrainian problem
why did i ask for a map of the united
states and mexico
what did you mean well the united states
has a pretty large border with mexico
now imagine that you have a revolution
in mexico
that's not that hard to imagine
and imagine that the government that
comes to power is not a big fan of the
united states of america
and i think that too is not difficult to
imagine
but since it's a little bit afraid of
big brother
it asks the russians to send over
three or four or five divisions to be
placed on the u.s
mexican border think the us would accept
that
so why would the russians accept this
that's what it's really all about does
there have to be a compromise in my
opinion yes
and the compromise has to be that
ukraine
guaranteed will not become a member of
nato
and then the compromise is that the
russians get out
we get out but there's the guarantee
crimea is a different issue
there could be an agreement that let's
do another referendum
under international supervision
let's see what the people of crimea want
do they really want to be part of russia
or do they want to be part of ukraine or
do they want to be an independent
republic
i know what the answer will be
overwhelmingly and so does everyone
which is why no one is even suggesting
that because the majority of the people
who live in
in crimea want to be part of russia it's
a tradition
it's existed that way for a long time
but basically that's my answer yes you
need a compromise
and if neither side is willing to
compromise
well then we're in deep uh
whatever can we unmute it though
we're over here for the next question
we'll
now i'm gonna switch to to english i
just wanted to greet you in in russian
um i've been following you for many
years your work um
going back to tele bridges uh with phil
donahue and
certainly some of us remember those days
i watched that back in the soviet union
i'm from ukraine
just for the record um so uh
i uh certainly shared your view
about a lot of things that you you speak
about
uh today however i'm struggling a little
bit
um to accept your point of view
and i can't get rid of a feeling that
it's almost like a legal defense that is
trying to
explain the bad behavior of a person
by the external circumstances
i'm certainly not naive or idealistic
about the policy making in any country
including the united states
and certainly i do agree that mistakes
were made
not being an expert in this field it's
difficult for me to really
know the exact uh chronological sequence
of the events
so it's difficult to argue what was the
cause and what was the effect
uh of what you're describing uh however
in your presentation today
i think you uh certainly presented mr
putin as
a positive peace-loving person
and i'm not sure that i agree with that
assessment
i don't know well you certainly
certainly brought up a number of facts
that presented him as somebody who was
continuously an ongoing basis reaching
out to
to the world not just the united states
but uh the west
uh with the peace mission in mind
however his actions um not just
vis-a-vis
crimea but overall eastern ukraine uh
his pretty aggressive actions in syria
certainly uh don't create that position
so i think there's a
little bit of a disconnect between uh
either that's the united states or our
policy makers
uh made that created that image of putin
as
uh somebody who is a not an easy person
to work with
here we go but certainly his actions in
many ways
uh in not just his actions but also the
aggressive tactics of the military
russian military in a lot of these
regions
uh don't support that that view um
but to get to my question i think uh
while
uh general if we uh for discussion sake
agreed to
uh accept that the us and
uh maybe the western world world
contributed in a way to that image of
putin that that you described
um um putin is not only responsible for
the foreign policy policy of the of the
russian federation but also for its
domestic policy
and who contributed to his image
as the domestic leader of russia as
somebody who is fairly
fairly authoritarian in the way he
runs the country thank you well that
wasn't a question but i'll answer it
um i made a point of up to 2007
and up to 2007 putin did nothing
internationally that would speak of an
aggression
nothing at all it all happened after
2007.
it happened in 2008 with georgia
with the war officially it wasn't putin
it was mid video but you know so
no big difference and then all the other
things that you're talking about
but up until 2007 until that munich
speech
when he said enough is enough you have
to respect us
you have to take into consideration our
interest
the world is not unipolar it is
multi-polar
and you will have to keep that in mind
incidentally that's why he's so popular
in russia
not because he contributed to people's
living much better although they did but
he was lucky because
the price of oil was high and so that
certainly helped
but because people saw him as someone
who stood up
to the american bully and told him off
and that's where his popularity comes
from russia is back
we're up from our knees as people would
say and they have to take us into
consideration
and we don't give a damn if you like us
so you don't like us
but you know putin is our man he is true
patriot
and that's where his strength lies now
if you talk about his domestic policies
i would absolutely agree with you that a
he's authoritarian
b he has pretty much stymied the
development of
democracy in russia
i do not agree with basically almost all
of his policies
in russia not all but almost all
i'm much more supportive of his
international views
than of his domestic views so i have no
argument with you
i did not present i don't think i did
present him as a
you know a lover of peace
i was simply making the point that up
until a certain moment
you could not really blame him for
anything
and that well i say find it just point
me you know say
well in 2006 or in 2005
russia did this and this i've you know i
i would say okay
fine i don't know what you know what
what's what are we talking about
and of course ukraine
with its uh proximity to russia
and have having been seen
always as close to russia
because of the language because of the
religion um
in a way the russians you know the ruse
being where russia was born uh
in ukraine so the fact that ukraine
would leave
very painful to russians as it would be
in you know in other countries
but um that certainly does not actually
put this that certainly does not
um
make putin blameless in what's happened
in ukraine
so i have no argument with you at all
but because of the mistakes that we're
making in my opinion
that were made you have now a man
who has a very different outlook than he
did
how many years ago now you know
and that's too bad i think that
there was a huge window of opportunity
and it was missed
and it's too bad for everyone
i see a hand right up here
um hi my name is anastasia i'm from
moscow so i grew up in russia but
i i've lived in the us now for five
years so
um we've talked a lot about putin and
how powerful he is
and his international policy but
you know being a russian myself i ask
myself
is there a future for russia should we
hope for anything
better should we because you know now
i feel like there is a big division in
terms of
what people think like some people just
think putin is everything
all we've all we've got and there is no
other future for us
but then of course with navalny being in
the picture and i know you're not the
fan of him
but um you know except for him of course
there might be someone else but
my question is should we hope for any
improvements in terms of like for us for
russians
should we hope for the future for russia
or should we just
practice our american accent and forget
about it
well you know um when you ask that
question i would have to ask
what do you mean um what would you like
to change
what is it that that makes you
ask that question
and my answer to that is of course
there's a future
and the future is well let me back up a
little bit here the main problem
from my point of view in russia is that
the leadership all the leadership
is soviet
all the people who are at the head of
politics and all the rest of it they're
all soviet they were born in the soviet
union
they went to soviet schools they were
members of the young pioneers
they were members of the young communist
league they were members of the
communist party
most of them they are
um they are they were
created formed
by a system that no longer exists
they're trying to run a system that they
really don't know anything about
and they're not very good at it but
whatever they do
is based on the mentality that they have
and that mentality is a soviet mentality
and there's not much you can do about
that
that's the way they were brought up
and you can't say well where are the
others because there are no others
and what i say is in my opinion uh
the hope is that people who were not
born
in the soviet union who were born
afterwards
that is to say the next generation and
the generation after that
that's when you will see real change
and you have to have patience i have no
doubt that russia is a great country
and you know during the worst times like
the tsar
nicholas the first during those years
russia's
greatest literature developed so
you know it's not that it's not just you
can't just look at it from
that side i certainly have hope i won't
see it
not at my age it's going to take another
20 30 years
but in all countries for democracy to
develop it took over 200.
and i guess there were people back then
saying gee do we have a future
because there are all kinds of things
you had slavery in the united states
less than 200 years ago come on
since you have to look at it
realistically
so my answer to you is yes i absolutely
do believe it
but it's going to take time and you
cannot do anything about that
except that if you're young you can look
forward
to a change that is inevitable because
those people will disappear
and it'll be your ball game
as a yankee fan i know what i'm saying
i'm here here right over there thank you
okay uh i'm a father of uh yale
undergrad
my name is olek we met 16 years ago in
kazakhstan we spent a couple of days in
media business remember that
but the question that i have um
and uh you know we had very interesting
discussions 16 years ago about what made
my family move to america from odessa
and you know and i i actually i saw a
lot about it
and now i know my answer and
but back then um
i believe i told you the story about my
father who really
you know after that conflict and
transnistria that was
100 kilometers from odessa when people
all of a sudden started killing each
other
you know geopolitics yeah we all
understand that this for that we
understand that
um you know united states and mexico
russia and ukraine southern border nato
fleet and sevastopol
we all understand that but with people
going and killing each other right now
in danisk
people who lived on the same street it's
not it's not even
karabakh it's not like even armenians
and zika virginia's
we had some ethnic conflicts right
they had some you know religious
differences
but whatever is going on in donbass
right now when neighbors are killing
neighbors
over nothing i mean
do you really think that that whole
issue of ukrainian language
is like really pressing there that or or
these stories that were made up about
you know
western ukrainians banderas you know
nazis
who's gonna move in who's gonna you know
how do we stop that how do we stop
people from killing each other
in situations like that because you know
they can meet up and minsk
they can do whatever you know they can
make agreements
they can disagree you know better than
me
about you know money interest and and
cryptocracy
that is so omnipresent in russia and
ukraine
and everywhere but how do we stop that
how do we stop
how can united states and germany and
russia
get together and stop brothers from
killing brothers
well you know um if i had the answers to
all of those things
i probably would be in a different job
seriously i mean i i have i can't tell
you how to solve
the world's problems and you know people
are killing each other
in many places in africa for instance
brother is killing brother and so on and
this is going on everywhere but i would
say
that if the leaders of russia
of ukraine of the united states
of germany were actually asking that
question
that question they were asking i think
they'd find a way to answer it
but i don't think they're asking that
question i think they're asking very
different questions
and they have very different aims
and that's why this is going on so i
to me the answer is pretty obvious
how you make people do that that's a
different question why is it
that egoistic
geopolitical interests take first place
over these things
that's the real question and when you
say we understand
i don't know who you're talking about
most people don't even know
you know in this country where georgia
is for instance
except the state of georgia
most people are really really and in
russia too and there's
there's a the the level of of knowledge
is lower than uh
than the doorstep as they say so
there is no effort and the media
does not play that game at all it
doesn't say
how do we stop it says they are to blame
and that's it and on both sides
so i think the only way to stop it is
for us to talk
make our voices heard and that's not
easy
and sometimes it's dangerous but
again if you know did i ever no of
course not
there was a guy by the name his last
name was knee muller it's a german
who fought during world war one he was
the youngest japanese
u-boat commander for the uboat as they
were called
submarines and when germany lost the war
he was totally crushed by it
and he became a priest protestant priest
in hamburg and very anti-war
and as he grew he as he uh went up the
ladder as it were hitler did too
and hitler became the head of germany
and he became the head of the protestant
church
in hamburg at the same time and he spoke
out against war
and finally he was arrested and he was
sent to a concentration camp
but he survived and when he came back he
wrote a book
and in that book there's a passage that
i know by heart
because i think it's one of the most
important and powerful things i've ever
heard
he wrote when they came for the jews
i didn't say anything because i'm not
jewish
and when they came for the communists i
didn't say anything
because i'm not a communist and when
they came for the trade union members
i didn't say anything because i'm not a
member of the trade union
and when they came for the catholics i
didn't say anything because
i'm not a catholic and when they came
for me
there was no one to speak
and i feel very i very much feel that
way if we don't speak out
whoever however we can and not
irresponsibly
and not to say oh look who you know look
at me
but rather with this understanding that
it's our
it's our human duty to do this well then
and yeah
we keep saying well they should do it
that's it's certainly very russian they
should do it
and if they don't then what
so that's really that's my view
and it's an idealistic view perhaps but
that's the way i look at it
okay hi i'm here so my name is
here um coincidentally i'm also
anastasia from moscow
hot savas here i'm a phd student at yale
so you started your talk by outlining
two strategies the u.s could have taken
towards the soviet union
towards russia towards russia after the
soviet union collapsed
and presented this as a cornerstone of
the situation we have right now
so if we hypothesize uh with your
knowledge
of russian politics economy you know the
soviet mentality that you mentioned
um do you believe that some version of
marshall plan
could have ever changed anything
well you know that's the question that
regardless of how i answer
i can't prove it because it didn't
happen
so it's kind of as you say it's very
hypothetical
but do i think that that would have been
better than what they did
yes clearly clearly it would have been
better
to what extent it would have succeeded
who knows i don't know
but i do know that when gorbachev
announced glossness
the media in russia changed dramatically
and i think nobody would argue with that
dramatically overnight it became a
different kind of media
during the soviet times 40 million
people
tuned into the voice of america in
russian
the bbc world service in russian the
deutsche bella
in russian because they were not getting
in their own media information that
they were getting on these way uh you
know and and the russians
tried to block that the soviet
government did
spent trillions of rubles trying to
block that
but people listened nonetheless as soon
as glasses came in they stopped
listening
they were getting it from their own sort
they were getting the information people
know exactly
when they're getting in when they're not
or usually they do
so that's one example of how quickly
things
changed so i do think
that had there been this attitude let's
help them
let's help them become democratic i do
think that it would have been a positive
that the result would have been positive
i can't tell you how positive so
that's you know my hypothetical answer
to your hypothetical question
i think we have uh two more uh time for
two more questions perhaps over here
thank you my name is asia i'm from
yerevan armenia right there on the map
wow yeah it is tiny but it's still there
you see it over there right that tiny
little
country that says armenia yes
so i'm a doctoral student and i study
genocides but today i'm going to ask a
question
genocide wow yeah a lot of fun
but today today i'm going to ask
a question about current developments uh
that happened right next door to russia
and are very connected to what you
talked about about speaking
out about speaking uh the new generation
that can change
the generation that maybe does not have
the soviet mentality
can change or may be the change and uh
something like that recently happened in
armenia no one ever expected that
peaceful demonstrations in such a tiny
post-soviet landlocked country could
lead to
a change which was
the collapse of the old rule and
establishment of
the government which is totally and
fully supported by the people
and uh the funny question that i always
hear when i discuss this
with students or at conferences
is how come russia did not
intervene into these developments
in any way and i would really
appreciate your opinion in this
like how come that vladimir putin
did not really respond in
any visual way to this development
and how would was this even
or was it observed seen
in russia because it was next door it
was a
big change and some people were even
speculating uh how this could serve as
an example for
other countries to topple their
governments etc so
thank you well
one reason might be that perhaps putin
isn't quite the man you'll think he is
you know that's a possibility i'm not
insisting on it
um another reason might be that the new
leader
of armenia never expressed any
anti-russian
sentiment on the contrary said we are in
an
an independent country but look where we
are
yeah and we've always had very close
ties with russia
and we want to have close times economic
ties
there was no absolutely no sense of of
um
enmity on the contrary and it was the
people
there was no doubt at this time it was
the people who spoke out
you know armenia is really a very small
country what's the population now
three million and there was a million
people that came out
can you imagine 30 of the entire
population
comes out in the streets you can't
ignore that
and that's another reason but
the very question why didn't putin
interfere reflects
the way people think about it because
that's the way he's been
depicted
so you know that's that's my that's my
answer incidentally um
well no i'm not i'm not going to go into
that uh
one more question you say i think one
more yeah we'll try to wrap up by six so
um we're back on this side if there's i
see a hand right
next to you below you um
hi i'm a master student in european and
russian studies um
i guess my question is about the
poisoning in the uk earlier this year
fine i'm sorry um
is there a way for us to respond to that
strongly um
that doesn't escalate the kind of
confrontational
paradigm yeah
you know when um
when this took place in salisbury
i was shocked
and i tried to figure out for myself
some kind of logic now you know why
who would do this and why now
you know let's forget about the child i
mean she's laying
you know she didn't do anything scrippo
um he was a military agent right
he worked for the former gru not for the
kgb
putin worked for the kgb he worked at
the gru which is military intelligence
and they can't stand the kgb and the kgb
can't stand military intelligence
that's normal competition so
and he betrayed his country let's face
it right he went over to the other side
and began to work for british
intelligence
and he was caught and he was tried
and he was sentenced to 13 years
now i don't know if you're familiar with
what happens to
spies who who who turn against their own
country
and are then caught well in wartime
they're shot
but in peacetime well it's usually
something like 30 years
25 13 is a weird sentence
not only does he get this rather short
sentence
considering but he's exchanged
for soviet excuse me russian spies who
were caught
now if he was exchanged that means that
he really didn't know anything
at that point he was no he was no danger
to the russian side so you know let him
go and we'll get ours back
now if putin now putin doesn't like
traders
who does if putin had wanted to kill him
he was in prison it was easier to do it
and you could say that he had a heart
attack or that he committed suicide or
whatever there was no problem killing
him when he was in jail in russia
but they let him go they exchanged them
they could have exchanged someone else
they exchanged him
what sense would it make
to poison this man under those
circumstances i mean logically
putin is anything but stupid it's not
stupid
it's very risky the risk of somehow this
being found out
is always there why do it this is not a
a dangerous person
he can't do anything he can talk about
what he knows but it's
over so i try to find i'm not saying
didn't do it i'm saying i'm trying to
find some kind of logic
logic not emotions logic as to why
putin would be involved in something
like that
all right it's not putin it's one of
those
lower you know one of the gru people who
think that putin would like it
if they did it
but would putin like it if it was
discovered
no of course not they get their head
chopped off
so why would they risk it they're not
going to get
decorations for doing it because if
putin had ordered it then yes
so why would they do it so to me it
really remains a mystery
because it's stupid it's
counterproductive
it doesn't do anything positive at all
so am i denying anything i'm not denying
i'm saying give me proof
please just show me yes there it is
now this interview did you see it the
interview
of rita what's her name some uh
simon yan with those two jer those two
people
did you see it it was one of the most
uh unprofessional
pieces of work that i've ever seen
that was just you know i thought what
who
why and it happened you know the day
before that putin had said
uh these two men should go to the media
and so they come the next day they're
there you know
it it's laughable except that it's not
not really so i would say to you that
whole story
is disgusting
i find it hard to believe that putin's
the initiate
what initiated it i really do
but somebody did there's no doubt about
it
ah now i've heard of a really nice story
you know that that uh mr skripal
in britain every time he'd meet with his
um handlers as they called them
he he would be paid a certain amount not
a lot you know five thousand
um pounds or 7 000 pounds or if you felt
you had something really interesting to
say
10 000 pounds but again he was of no
real interest so i'm thinking and now
this is john le correa right i'm
thinking
british intelligence gets together and
says we don't need this guy anymore
and he's costing us money and he's not
giving
now why don't we
and naked look like it's putin well
that's brilliant
chop we should do this you know
so british intelligence poisons the guy
and the whole thing works this way
it's not impossible i kind of laughed at
myself when i came up with that one
and i'd like to talk to mr lickare and
see how he thinks
incidentally if you've not read his last
two books
the pigeon tunnel which is a
story of his life as a spy
and the other one i forgot legacy of a
spy
um he
writes with total disgust about that
profession
that he was in for so long i mean really
um so you know there it is i
my answer to you is i i just don't know
it's such a weird thing it really is i
see no reason for it it's just
just invading another country i can
explain right but this i
i don't know it makes no sense
one day we'll know the real the real
thing oh incidentally saul's very
i don't know if you've ever been there i
was there uh i
i shot a documentary about england and
so you know why i went there
not because the steeple is i don't know
how many feet high or something
i had no idea it's a beautiful uh
beautiful church actually but um
it's because they have their one of the
three
original copies of the magna carta
and that's the beginning of real
democracy in the west well if you call
if you don't count the ancient greeks
and i really wanted to see it and they
brought it out and i can't tell you what
you know when you look at that and you
say what was it 12
15 and they were already saying you
can't put a man in prison
without proving that he's committed a
crime
and you have all the kings and queens
and all of that it's amazing
that's why i went there these guys
didn't even know it was there right
they went to see the steeple let me come
on all right unbelievable
let me thank everyone for for listening
[Music]
you